[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETE LEPAGE: --Thursday.
I want to welcome Paul, who's
joining us from London.
Paul, you want to say hi?
PAUL KINLAN: Hi, guys.
PETE LEPAGE: Excellent.
So today's a kind of cool day.
Today's the first of a new
weekly series that we're going
to be starting for Mobile Web
Thursdays, where we're going
to be coming to you with all
kinds of really cool stuff
about mobile web development.
Today, we're going to focus on
the launch of Chrome for
Android, the latest build
that shipped yesterday.
Paul, do you want to tell us
a little bit about what's
special about this new build?
PAUL KINLAN: What's special?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Everything.
It's actually a really exciting
build, right?
Because this is the first time
where we're getting close to
parity with the desktop.
We both wanted web developers
to have a first class
experience when developing
for the web,
across all factory devices.
And obviously in the past,
we've led with desktop.
And then, we launched,
I think 16, and then
upgraded to 18 on Android.
And now we're at 25, only a week
behind the actual desktop
launch, like version
25 Chrome.
So for me, that's the
most exciting thing.
Because developers are at
least starting to get
consistent platforms to target
across all form factors.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
I think that's sort of the
neatest thing for me, as well.
The fact that we are now on M
25, or only a week behind the
desktop build is
pretty awesome.
So if you haven't updated your
Chrome for Android on your
Android device, you
should go do that.
If you just go into the Play
store, if you haven't seen the
update pop up, and check for any
available updates so that
you can get that.
PAUL KINLAN: I actually think
you need a user permission
change, as well, for the audio
stuff, which we're going to
talk about later.
So if you see it sitting
there, press
update, and go ahead.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
I think that we'll talk
about that in a bit.
But that's a really cool new
feature that I'm really
excited about.
So why don't we dive in and take
a look at some of the new
things that are available
in Chrome for Android.
So there's a couple of ones that
are kind of cool that are
a little bit harder to show.
But some of those are like,
improved scrolling
performance.
So I'm going to bring
up a page here.
And I'm just going to create a
new tab, and do a quick search
for how browsers work.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
a big doc, right?
PETE LEPAGE: And that's a
huge document, right?
So that's the one
on HTML5 Rocks.
So if I pull this guy up and
let it finish loading.
In the past, if you started
scrolling on here, what you'd
find would be that you'd get
big blank spots showing up.
You'd get pieces where content
just didn't render.
But now, notice that as I'm
scrolling, we're getting very
few of those blank spots--
and of course, as we
go through a demo.
But every once in a while, we
get these areas where we get
sort of blurred out text.
What's happening is the
browser's rendering low
quality images, effectively, so
that it can show and scroll
quickly so that we can see
what's going on, so that we
get a much better experience.
And we get a much smoother
scrolling experience going on.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So everyone knows, this is
like basically a threaded
compositor now.
So in the past, essentially,
paints and everything used to
block the--
if you did a paint and then a
render, it would block the
actual browser for that time.
And now it doesn't.
It's on a completely
separate thread.
Internally, we called it
imple-side threading, or
imple-side painting,
I'm sorry.
It's like a completely
obtuse name.
But essentially, what it does
is exactly what Pete just
described, where you'll
do a scroll.
And we've got low resolution
versions of the page that's
all rendered out anyway.
We've got low resolution
versions of the page which we
can quickly show to the user.
And then when the scrolling
stops, we swap that out.
And we give it back to the
user in full, high res.
And we think this is a better
way of doing it, because
that's one of the worst things
that we have at the moment on
the mobile web, is if you
scroll, you lose track of
everything.
The app would try to paint,
but the user wouldn't see
anything, because we
couldn't keep up.
And this is a big improvement
for the way that you develop
apps, or at least the
way that your users
see your site snaps.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
This is a really cool one.
And it really is going to, I
think, increase the feeling
that users have of a responsive
browser and a
responsive website.
So that's one.
One of the next ones is really
sort of improved performance
in pinch to zoom sites.
So in sites where you're going
to go to them and you're going
to go and do pinch to zoom,
the performance there is
significantly improved.
Paul, do you want to talk
a little bit about that?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
It's kind of hard to
show this off.
But I think it's basically a
benefit of having the threaded
compositor now.
The interesting thing, and we
found this out a couple of
weeks ago, is that we always
have this like 300 millisecond
delay on clicks.
You click a link, or
click anything.
Obviously, it needs to work out
whether you're going to
try to do another
type of gesture.
And that whole subsystem's been
starting to be improved.
But the interesting thing is if
you have your viewport set,
which we might talk about
viewport today, but we
probably have a whole dedicated
session for
viewports in the future.
Because it's quite a
complex subject.
If you have your viewport set to
device width, then we don't
even do that 300 millisecond
delay.
Because we know that you're not
going to do another type
of gesture.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
PAUL KINLAN: Because it's
impossible to do, basically.
So that's the whole subset of
performance improvements that
have been coming along with the
viewport and the page to
zoom stuff and everything.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, yeah.
I think that one's
pretty slick.
And that one's a nice user
improvement, as well.
PAUL KINLAN: In theory, it means
that you don't need to
use FastClick.
But obviously, every other
browser out there that is
using FastClick has this
other problem, as well.
So we'll probably see that
type of thing live for a
little while.
But the idea is that we want to
give you the ability just
to not have to use
that library.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
And well, one of the things that
we were talking about a
couple weeks ago while we were
in London for Edge was talking
with the developers
of FastClick.
And talking about ways that we
could potentially detect
Chrome for Android with
the proper things set.
And if everything is set
properly, not even load
FastClick, so that it doesn't
even have to load.
There's less JavaScript
running on your page.
Your page is more responsive
because of that.
And your clicks happen pretty
much instantly.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, yeah.
PETE LEPAGE: So I think that's
a pretty slick one.
There's also a whole bunch of
work that we did around making
sure that we had the latest
JavaScript engine.
So effectively, the previous
version of
Chrome was Chrome 18.
We've moved seven versions of
Chrome since then, and had
seven releases since
that initial time.
So we now have a much faster
JavaScript engine with all of
the latest V8 stuff in there.
Again, that one's a little
hard to demo, as well.
So don't really have a lot to
show there, but I think we
have something cool for the--
PAUL KINLAN: I mean, people can
just go to the SunSpider
stuff if they want.
PETE LEPAGE: That's
a good point.
PAUL KINLAN: We've been talking
with Paul Lewis and a
couple of other guys as well,
internally, about the
JavaScript performance, OK, it's
a big factor in how your
application responds
to the users.
But bigger areas of improvement
that you could
potentially have as a developer
when you're
optimizing your site are
actually around rendering
paint, and actually not
forcing layouts.
Because obviously, the browsers
on mobile phones are,
in order of magnitude, slower
than desktop machines.
So we have a bigger benefit in
reducing the number of reflows
and recalcs and all those type
of things, than necessarily
the JavaScript stuff itself.
But that being said, we
are keeping parity.
And that's the aim, is to keep
parity with the desktop now.
So I think that's a really
powerful thing.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So now we've got another whole
set of features where we've
got some really cool demos.
If you want to follow along or
try any of these demos, we can
put the link on the screen
for the demos.
But you can see the link is
there, and you can try some of
these yourself.
So the first one I want to have
a quick peek at is the
audio demo.
And one of the big changes there
is now, audio will play
even if Chrome's in
the background.
And Paul had mentioned that
you need a background--
you need a user permission to
update Chrome for Android.
And this is why.
So if I were to go and say, hey,
I want to start playing
this podcast.
Which we'll go and
hit play here.
Sure enough, OK.
You can hear it in
the background.
Now, if I leave Chrome and go
somewhere else within my phone
and start doing other things,
the podcast keeps going.
So if I'm using something like
Google music to play music, if
I'm listening to podcasts or
doing anything else, all of
that music or all of that audio
still keeps playing,
even with Chrome not as
the primary piece.
So I can go and check
out some news, see
what's going on there.
It's a pretty slick and kind
of cool little feature.
Paul, do you have anything you
want to add to this one?
PAUL KINLAN: No, this actually,
so this is--
I think we're playing the HM
part as well, I think.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: This is actually
a feature that Mike
[INAUDIBLE] wanted
quite a long time
ago inside the browser.
He's had a bug open for
it for quite a while.
And we finally have been able to
actually fix it, because of
all the kind of changes
and everything.
So I'm hoping Mike's happy.
This is a big shout out
to him, as well.
Because it's actually
a big change.
There's a lot of things that you
might have to, well, you
don't have to worry too much
about web audio at the moment.
But you might be caught-- there
might be situations
where you would want to
know that the user's
background of your page.
So you need to still be
respectful of the user if
you're playing audio on.
You might have to deal
with that, still.
Actually, you probably should
deal with that.
Just be respectful.
But then, you've got this whole
class of applications
like podcast players.
And people watch the news on,
say, BBC News, and want to go
off and do other things.
And we can let that happen.
I think the interesting thing
to know is in theory, what
should happen is if another
action interrupts this,
whether a user gets a phone--
say a user, you know, a person--
they get the phone
call while this is happening.
The music stops playing, and
the audio stops playing.
And I don't believe
it resumes.
So it's just stopped.
But that's cool.
That's way more further than
we've been in the past.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, absolutely.
Cool.
So the next one is CSS Calc.
And I'll bring this one up.
And Paul, do you want to talk
a little bit about this one?
So I'll open the page.
And we've got this guy
showing right now.
PAUL KINLAN: I'm hoping it's
the correct version.
Because I found a bug just
before we started.
PETE LEPAGE: It's version two.
PAUL KINLAN: Then we
should be good.
But basically, what CSS Calc is
is this ability to perform
basic calculations inside CSS.
So for instance, you
could say well, my
width is normally 50%.
But I want it to be an
extra 10 pixels.
Well, you could never really
do that in CSS at the time.
You couldn't combine
calculations together.
Well, you can now.
And it's been in Chrome
25 for a while.
I believe in M 26, at least at
the moment, it's on prefix.
But right now, on the Android
browser, which was the bug I
found earlier on, it's prefixed
with hyphen calc.
The rest of the
functionality's exactly the same.
But it lets you do those little
things like, I want to
add 30 pixels to two EMs.
I want to do 50% minus 55%.
You can even do those types
of things to keep
the units the same.
It just gives you a lot more
flexibility when you're
designing your layouts.
And it's actually there now
inside everyone's latest
stable Chrome.
So that's pretty good.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
The coolest thing to me about
this is being able to go and
use different values or
different formats.
It's just always been one of
those things where you're
like, oh crap, I
did it in this.
And now I need to do--
and now you can do this
much more easily.
So bringing Chrome for Android
really closer to parity with
desktop is a really big
theme of this launch.
One of the next ones is support
for shadow DOM.
So I'll bring up
this demo here.
And I think this one's
kind of cool.
And we'll take a look
at the source for
this in a couple minutes.
But Paul, do you want to just
sort of explain again what's
going on on this one?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So I find it awkward to explain
the shadow DOM sometimes.
But in this demo, at least,
anyway, it's a picture of a
badge that says,
my name is Bob.
And when you look at the HTML,
you'll probably see the fact
that you'll just see this
element, which is just the
basic element.
There's basically a div inside
there which says, Bob.
It doesn't say anything else.
It just says, Bob.
But we've got this big rendering
on the outside of
the badge, and some
other text, and a
lot of other things.
And essentially, what's been
enabled in M 25 is the ability
to create a shadow root.
And the shadow root is this
entry point into this DOM that
you never see as a web developer
when you look at the
view source.
You have to enable shadow DOM
inspection inside the
developer tools.
But you don't actually see it.
And the idea is that, well,
you might have these third
party controls or these extra
controls for your user
interface elements.
And all you really want to see
in your HTML is the fact that
you know that you've got
that thing in there.
And that's what it's
basically doing.
It's created via some JavaScript
at the moment.
So you get a reference to the
element that you want to
enhance, say to create
a shadow root.
And that's it.
You basically can start
re-projecting the content from
the shadow root onto the
actual main DOM itself.
It's pretty nebulous at the
moment, in my understanding,
and especially the demo.
You can't really see much.
I know when we show you the
code, hopefully it will become
a lot clearer.
But it basically allows you
to make components.
You've got the template tag in
there as well, which is kind
of interesting.
But yeah, you can start to build
these nice components.
But the user face in HTML--
is that a way of saying it?--
is a lot simpler.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
I think the thing that is really
going to be interesting
about this is that the ability
to be able to build
components.
So today, you can go to jQuery
UI, or you can use things like
Bootstrap, that kind of stuff.
And it gives you a set
of components.
But you usually have to wrap
HTML and HTML to get a bunch
of things to happen.
And it works, and it's
a perfectly good
way of doing things.
But wouldn't it be great to be
able to say, calendar control.
And it goes and puts the right
calendar in, and you can style
it all appropriately.
You get the things
that you want.
And that's where I think the
shadow DOM is really going to
become a really powerful
and interesting piece.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Like I said, it's
a bit powerful.
You might not start to use
it for a little while.
But the fact is, it's consistent
across Chrome now.
And it's there across all
of our instances.
Not like our version of Chrome
that you get from all the
places that you normally get
them, whether it's the store,
or whether it's from the web or
the normal desktop version,
then you will have shadow
DOM enabled.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
And this is something that's
coming to other
browsers, as well.
This is not just a
Chrome feature.
These are open web platform
features, right?
Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: It's cool.
PETE LEPAGE: And that's
something, as well, that's
also pretty cool.
So yeah, right now,
it's just here.
But it's coming to
other browsers.
You'll be able to use this
in other places, as well.
Awesome, all right.
So let's get out of here.
So we'll close this guy,
and have a look
at the iUser timings.
Now, with desktop browsers,
we've been able to go and get
user timings for quite
some time.
And it's pretty powerful to be
able to understand how many
milliseconds it's taking for
your navigations to happen,
for your pages to load, so you
can really understand where
the bottlenecks are.
And now in Chrome for Android
in the latest
release, we have that.
So we can go and see, OK, well,
so in this particular
instance, our navigation
started at--
I'm not even going to try
and read that number.
It looks like we have
an undefined for
our navigation end.
So that may just be
a bug in the code.
PAUL KINLAN: There's
actually a few of
the standard elements.
Basically, when I built
the sample, I took
everything from the spec.
And then there's some across
different browsers which
aren't quite implemented, which
is why you get undefined.
But there's the whole load
of navigation stuff.
I think there's some DMS
ones in there, as well.
This is information
that you never get
outside of dev tools.
But you might want an instrument
inside your
application.
Like, I've not seen anyone do it
just yet, but I would like
to see people starting to pipe
their representation lists
into Google Analytics.
So that they can kind of start
to see different response
times, and how fast things
are, how that materially
affects the users,
essentially.
And that's what this
enables on desktop.
It's now on mobile.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
And I think one of the other
things that, this is really
important on mobile.
Because mobile performance is
completely different in many
ways than desktop
web performance.
Because you're going over a 3G
or a 4G radio, or sometimes
even Edge or GPRS, your
performance's characteristics
are going to be significantly
different.
So to understand how you
can make sure that your
performance on your mobile
website and your mobile web
apps is optimized, this is a
really good tool for being
able to dig into those and
see what's going on.
All right.
So support for the
track element.
Let's go for that one.
This one I think is
kind of cool.
And if you're familiar with the
track element, the track
element allows you to
add captioning or
text tracks to videos.
So if you were watching this
video after the fact, and you
see the numbers of the text
that's showing up, it would
show up below.
So in this case, I'm going
to go hit play on
this particular video.
And we'll scroll down
here in a sec.
And you can see that below,
we've got the text is showing
up below the video.
And we also have the video
playing quite nicely, as well.
You can see the little CC
icon there, as well.
Paul, do you have anything you
want to add for this one?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, actually,
this is kind of
interesting, this one.
This is a demo made by
Sam Dutton, one of my
colleagues in the UK.
And basically, he's
really into media.
And he's been all over
the track element for
quite a while now.
But the interesting thing about
this is there's actually
a book in what we know as Chrome
for Android 25, which
is this version.
Where if you look at the video,
you'll probably see
black lines across the very
bottom of the video.
That's actually the text track
apparently where it's been
made a little bit too small.
So this is it.
So what happens is underneath,
where you actually see the
text, and it says--
I'm a little bit delayed, but
I can see it says under what
happens, if there was change,
and all that type of stuff.
That's actually triggered by the
events from the track API.
So the track API is firing
events when the new captions
should come in, and all
this type of stuff.
And then Sam is basically
looking at what that DOM
element is, re-projecting it
onto the page as the timing
changes, basically.
So it's a little
bit of a hack.
But the fact is that you get
this information out anyway,
so you can go and do whatever
you want with the different
types of track information.
So it's pretty cool.
I expect that'll probably be
fixed at some point soon.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Well, I'm going to switch
out the phone,
and plug in my laptop.
Paul, do you want to talk about
some of the changes to
the viewport so that I
can set up and show
some of the dev tools?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So the viewport, it's never
that [INAUDIBLE].
But there's been some changes,
essentially with the way that
we handle viewport in the last
couple of weeks, at least.
And the change is the difference
between the old
Android browser and then the
Chrome browser on Android.
And basically, there's an
attribute when you're actually
setting up your viewport where
you set user scale.
Like min scale, max scale, the
width of the viewport, whether
it matches the device script,
or it's something else.
And then there's one extra
tag which is I
think target density.
And you can basically say target
density equals device
density DPI, or something
similar to that.
We've detected quite a few sites
that actually exist out
there with this set.
It doesn't do anything
anymore.
It's been removed.
Basically, no other browser
supports it anymore.
Because we have better ways of
actually detecting the users',
essentially the users' DPI,
which you can do via
JavaScript and CSS itself,
[INAUDIBLE]
in a media inquiry.
So it's been removed.
If you've got it, you
can remove it.
It's safe to remove it.
Don't worry about it so much.
And that's pretty much it.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
That's a big one.
There's a blog post that we just
put up, recommending that
people stop using that.
If you haven't gone and tested
your site, you should go and
just do a quick run through
of your site.
Just to make sure that it is
working as you expect it to
work in this new way.
Because we found a few
particular sites where it just
doesn't work as expected.
PAUL KINLAN: Did we do content
security policy?
PETE LEPAGE: We didn't talk
about content security policy.
Go for it.
PAUL KINLAN: Do we got a couple
of seconds to do that?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, OK.
So content security policy is
enabled in M 25 in Chrome,
which means enabled in M 25 for
Android Chrome, as well.
And basically, if you've ever
watched any of the Chrome apps
Hangouts that me and [INAUDIBLE]
do, you'll see us
talk about content security
policy all the time.
So you're probably OK
with this, right?
But for everyone else who
hasn't heard of content
security policy, it basically--
it's a set of
directives that you can include
in your HTTP headers
on the response back that
indicate essentially what type
of domains that requests can
come from from the site.
It's essentially there to
mitigate cross site scripting.
So you can basically say,
I don't allow scripts--
I only want to allow scripts
from my domain.
I don't want to allow scripts
from any other site.
And I don't want
to allow eval.
I don't want to allow
new function.
I don't want to allow any
inline script, as well.
Because inline script's
an interesting one.
If someone can inject a script
tag into your page, well, they
can cross site script
your page.
And the idea behind content
security policy is you can
actually turn that
feature off.
So you can say, people can't--
basically, they might be able
to insert a script.
But they can't insert any old
piece of JavaScript that they
choose to execute themselves.
So you can do those types things
of things, as well.
And that's there.
It's available.
And if you want to speak to
Mike West, one of our
colleagues based in Germany, in
Munich, he would be telling
you to turn it on now.
I think that's really
good advice.
He'd also tell you to
learn HTTPS, which
again, you should do.
But you combine these two pieces
of technology together,
and we start to get
more secure sites.
We mitigate a lot of risks by
having these things enabled.
But it requires browser support,
and it's in the
browser now.
PETE LEPAGE: Yep.
Yeah, that's a really
good point.
All right, well, I've got the
remote debugger set up.
So you should be able
to see that.
I also want to point
out, if we could
put the link to questions.
If you have questions as we're
going through, we'd love to
take your questions.
So you can post your questions
there on Moderator.
As soon as we finish up here on
some of the dev tool stuff,
we'll be popping
over to there.
So post your questions
to Google Moderator.
And I will go, and let's have
a quick peek at some of the
stuff that's available
on dev tools.
So first one I want to actually
have a look at is the
shadow DOM stuff.
I'm actually going to go and
we'll reload this page here,
so we can get the shadow
DOM test loaded.
And if have a look at the
elements here, if I can get
this guy to load.
Uh oh.
I always love when the demo gods
go not so happy on you on
fun little demos.
Let's see if we can
get this going.
Do, do, do, do, do.
I had this working
earlier today.
It did work, trust me.
All right.
Well, let me do this.
Let me try restarting Chrome.
PAUL KINLAN: I think to explain
problem for everyone
who's not used dev tools,
basically the dev tools that
you see inside normal Chrome
that you connect to your web
page to inspect, we have that
available in Android.
And the way that you do it is
that you have to use the
Android FDK to download ADB.
And we kind of know that's
a bit of a problem.
But you have to use this tool,
ADB, which lets you forward
requests from your machine
to your USB
connected Android device.
And then once you do that,
and you can actually
then use the dev tools.
Because dev tools, if you don't
remember, this is on
Android, it's pretty much the
same version of Chrome.
So it has the same kind of dev
tools experiments, same type
of kit and everything
inside dev tools.
You connect to that, and then
you get that whole ability
from the client, which is your
main machine's connected to
your mobile phone with
the dev tools.
And because they're the same,
the dev tools are actually
served up by the phone, and not
necessarily Chrome itself,
you get all the latest
improvements.
So if you're on M 18, which is
the last version for Android,
you'd have the M 18 dev tools.
Been a lot of improvements in
between, including a lot of
profiling changes.
So you'll basically see
these come up now.
And you've got the ability to
connect, use the dev tools
that's on the machine.
And you get a lot of goodness
out of it, including
performance profile,
DOM inspection, all
that type of magic.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
A reload helped.
So if we have a quick peek at
the one where we were talking
about the shadow DOM, you can
see I've got this template ID
equals name tag template.
And if I expand this out, I've
got all of the details that
are in there.
Now, I think in my particular
case, I'm going to bring up
the settings, so that I can see
what's in my particular
settings, I've got the show
shadow DOM turned on.
Let me turn that off,
and reload this page
so that we can see--
oh, it's still there.
All right, never mind.
So with that, you can go in and
be able to dig into the
shadow DOM.
You can be able to go and
see the different
elements that are there.
You can see all of the
other additional
settings that are available.
So if we have a look at some
of the new stuff that's
available within the settings,
there's now the show shadow
DOM, so that we can go in and
see what's going on there.
There's also these two
rendering, show paint
rectangles and show FPS meter.
So if I turn on the show FPS
meter, we all of a sudden get
the ability to see the number
of frames per second that's
being rendered on my device.
So I can see that right now,
this is rendering at about 60
frames per second.
Not like there's a whole heck
of a lot happening.
So not a big deal.
And we can also turn on
the paint rectangles.
So as we go through and try
and change things on this
particular page, we
can see where
things are getting painted.
Now, this is not exactly the
best example of this.
Because there's not a lot
on this particular page.
But you get the idea that you
can see as things are getting
repainted, where that painting
is truly happening.
The ability for source maps is
in there, just as you would
expect, as is on the desktop.
As well, we can show the CPU
activity on the ruler.
If I pop over to some of the
overrides, let me make this a
little bit bigger so we can see
it, you can override the
user agent.
So if you want to fake out
Chrome for Android and make
the website think that it's
running something else, maybe
you want to see how a website
is serving different content
for an iOS device versus a
Chrome device, you can go in,
and you can change that.
You can also--
go ahead.
PAUL KINLAN: I was going
to say, you just hit
the nail on the head.
It's like, we've been doing a
lot of work with trying to see
which sites do what.
And there are still sites that
try, basically, they'll
specialize for iOS or specialize
for Android.
Because they think iOS
has got a feature.
And then they'll override a
feature that is already
implemented in Chrome for
Android, essentially.
And if you change the user
agent, you can kind of test to
see whether the iPhone version
essentially works better.
Then you'll kind of know
whether they do
that type of thing.
It's nice.
PETE LEPAGE: In fact, this
is a really good example.
One of the things that we found
when we were looking at
the viewport settings was that
a lot of sites who were using
the device density DPI attribute
in their viewport,
they would use it only on
Chrome or on Android.
But they wouldn't send
it to iOS devices.
So one of the ways that I was
able to test and figure out
oh, hang on, what's the best fix
for some of these sites?
Was by going and changing the
user agent to iOS and being
like hey, just give us this.
It works perfectly.
And that was a really
easy fix for them.
You can also go in and override
your geolocation
settings, the device
orientation.
Emulate touch events, that one's
kind of one of those
things that's in there because
it's available on the desktop.
And you don't really need to
emulate them on the mobile
device, but it's there anyway.
And you can also emulate some
of the CSS properties.
PAUL KINLAN: That's cool.
I really like dev tools.
I'm hoping that we
get [INAUDIBLE]
mobile specific dev
tools session.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
I think that's a really
valuable thing.
And we'll try and get them on
within the next couple weeks.
Because there's a lot of new
stuff available, and I think a
lot of really interesting and
powerful things available for
us as developers.
So that's sort of the end of
the stuff that I wanted to
show really quickly
in the dev tools.
Paul, was there anything
else that you think
is worthy of a highlight?
PAUL KINLAN: Dev
tools wise, or?
PETE LEPAGE: Dev tools, or
actually anything else,
because I think at this point,
we've covered most of the
stuff that we wanted to.
PAUL KINLAN: I think there's a
lot of stuff under the hood
just infiltrating.
[INAUDIBLE] compositor,
it's a big change.
Basically, you'll see the
difference when you scroll
through any site.
Because you'll see the
content still.
So at the same time, we want a
lot of feedback about your
experiences with the
developer tools, or
with the latest version.
Especially if you're a
developer, and you found
something that doesn't work
quite as you'd expect.
[INAUDIBLE].
So yeah, send us all the
reports you want.
Also, send us feedback
on what you want to
hear about, as well.
Because we have some ideas,
but obviously, we want you
guys to learn things from what
we're talking about.
And we're not going to
do a what's new in
Android every week.
PETE LEPAGE: We don't ship
every week, yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Exactly right.
But at the same time, there's
going to be a
lot of stuff coming.
And we're going to have a whole
lot of new features to
talk to you about.
PETE LEPAGE: So that's
a really great point.
With Chrome for Android, you can
run Chrome Beta and Chrome
Stable side by side.
You can't do that
on the desktop.
And so if you want to see what's
coming, you want to
play with some of those things,
that's a really great
way to see what's coming,
and just sort
of see what's exciting.
PAUL KINLAN: Actually, one thing
I did want to talk about
is that I think in this one,
you can use about flags.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, that, yes!
PAUL KINLAN: You've got the
ability now in stable Chrome
to be able to toggle all
of these settings.
One, especially if you're a
games developer and you want
to do WebGL on mobile, and
pretty much Firefox is the
only option, you could enable
that and test it inside your
browser now.
It's not available on
the general web.
It has to be enabled
by a Chrome flags.
But things like WebGL,
especially, these are the
technologies which we want to
get out there, but we don't
think are quite ready
just yet.
We'd love feedback on all these
other features, as well.
Or you've got uses for
them, at least.
Chrome flags, interestingly,
all the normal Chrome colon
slash slash URLs would work.
So if you want to go and check
what appcache is doing, Chrome
colon slash slash appcache
internals, those types of
things, you get the full
accessible of what you need on
the device.
And you don't have to enable
developer [INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: That's
pretty slick.
Cool.
Well, why don't we switch
over and take
some of your questions.
I'm going to bring this up.
And if you guys have questions
that you want to post, please
feel free to post those
to the Moderator.
We'll put the link up there.
And let me load questions.
Maybe it's slow internet
day here at Google.
PAUL KINLAN: I've got the
questions, if you want.
PETE LEPAGE: OK yeah, why
don't we just switch
to the two of us.
And you can go for questions,
and we can
take them from there.
PAUL KINLAN: We've got
two questions.
The first one is, any plans to
make available camera capture
via getUserMedia and WebRTC
in Chrome for Android?
Pete?
PETE LEPAGE: Sure, absolutely.
I want to answer this question
a little bit more generally.
Because I think it's a little
bit more fun to do that.
And it gives you a little
bit more excitement
about what's coming.
The plan is to really get
desktop and phone parity.
So we want to make sure that
the same features that are
available for Chrome for
desktop are available.
Now, it may take
a little while.
And some of these things, you
may see behind flags.
But we do plan to get everything
as close to feature
parity as possible.
In fact, that's one you
can check out today.
If you go into Chrome
colon [INAUDIBLE]
flags, you can turn WebGL on in
Chrome M 25, which you can
see, these are things that
are moving forward.
It is behind a flag right now,
so that we can make sure that
we get it right.
We can not have somebody go
do something, it's like
absolutely beautiful but kind
of slow, or has a bad
experience.
We want to make sure that we
provide that great experience.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Parity's our thing.
We're not saying that we're
completely there just yet.
But we've come a long,
long way in a
relatively short time.
So I'm hopeful.
The interesting thing, if you
want to access the camera,
there's always the import
type you [INAUDIBLE]
accepts camera, or accepts
image type.
And then capture camera
and capture camcorder.
It'll let you do
video, as well.
So you do have access to them.
And they're still in there.
It's not as nice, obviously.
It's not as sexy.
It's not as inline
as you expect.
Everyone wants that Instagram
experience.
I mean, we do have a basic
solution in lieu of that.
Watch the space for all
the other features.
We want parity.
Second question is
about extensions.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Are we bringing
extensions anytime soon?
PETE LEPAGE: I don't think we
have anything to announce at
this point.
I know it's something that we're
certainly interested in.
The biggest concern that I
have around extensions is
really around performance and
accessibility on stuff.
On a desktop where you can have
all sorts of little icons
next to your address bar, where
you can take a little
bit of a performance hit,
because you're doing some
JavaScript processing.
Or maybe you're going and
pulling some additional
resources, and putting
them on a page.
That's OK, because you've
got a powerful computer.
On a phone or tablet, you
don't have that much
processing power.
So I think it's really important
that when we do
tackle this, we make sure
we tackle it right.
And we don't end up doing
anything that's going to cause
performance implications
for users.
Cool.
PAUL KINLAN: That's it.
I think that's all
the questions.
There's none on YouTube.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
PAUL KINLAN: So yeah,
I think we're--
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
I want to say thanks everybody
for joining us.
Thanks, Paul, for joining
us from London.
We're going to be doing
this every Thursday.
So we'll be back next Thursday
at the same time.
And hope to see you then.
Thanks, everybody.